madame monsieur bonsoir l'art que
l'association pour la recherche sur le
cancer sévèrement épinglée par la cour
des comptes ce sont nos confrères de
libération qui ont révélé ce matin les
grandes lignes du rapport des magistrats
qui révèle entre autres que 27 %
seulement des sommes engagées par l'arc
en 93 ont concerné l'aide à la recherche
plus grave la cour des comptes considère
que certaines anomalies relève
d'éventuelles poursuites judiciaires en
quête thierry kurt et philippe boisserie
voici le rapport dans libération révèle
le contenu 58 pages qui analysent au
plus près les ressources gérées par
l'arc en 1993
un bilan qui multiplie les critiques la
première touche à l'efficacité 27 % des
fonds seulement vont à la recherche
c'est à dire que sur 100 francs
collectés 73 francs se perdent à tout
autre chose
l'arcp conteste le chiffre fourel 76%
irait à la recherche deuxième mise en
cause le coût réel des collectes selon
la cour des comptes l'association le
minimise par des jeux d'écriture
pourtant près des deux tiers du budget
sont consacrés à ces frais ou à des
dépenses de communication et de
prévention anomalies aussi concernant le
personnel et les crédits souligne la
cour des comptes certains salariés payés
par le cnrs disent les magistrats le
sont aussi par l'arc sans rien dire à
personne quant aux crédits alloués à la
recherche ils ne se font guère plus dans
la transparence moins de 60 % le sont
après avis d'une commission scientifique
à l'aspect discrétionnaire des
subventions s'ajoutent le rôle
prépondérant du bureau de l'association
c'est à dire de quelques personnes il y
a cinq ans l'igas l'inspection générale
des affaires sociales avait déjà révélé
une bonne part de ses doutes l'arc avait
saisi la justice l'igas n'étaient pas
habilités pour ce genre d' enquête selon
jacques crozemarie le président de l'arc
il a fermé la porte à la mission de
l'igas le 20 novembre donc dix jours
avant la décision du tribunal
administratif et il a fait au moment où
les investigations de l'inspection
portait sur tout le secteur
communication et notamment s'intéressait
à des sociétés sous traitantes qui
utilisait la majorité des fonds
collectés les appels d'offres pour ces
sociétés soulève aussi des
interrogations
les budgets arrive souvent au même
endroit c'est à dire ici au siège de la
société international development dont
la porte nous est restée fermée tout le
monde était soi-disant en vacances ce
soir l'avocat de l'arc conteste toutes
ses conclusions une question demeure
celle d'une possible illégalité la cour
des comptes a transmis son rapport au
parquet de paris
et le conseil d'administration de l'arq
tiendra demain une réunion
extraordinaire créant 62 l'association
pour la recherche sur le cancer regroupe
environ 3 millions d'adhérents et
recueille chaque année quelque 600
millions de francs à la tête de l'arc
jacques crozemarie qui disposent sur
cette association d'un pouvoir quasi
théocratique jean daniel flaysakier
50000 cancers associés au virus son
président l'arc c'est la création de
jacques crozemarie en 1962 cet agent
administratif du cnrs ni médecin ni
chercheurs ont créé une association ce
fil du temps va devenir le leader
européen dans le domaine du cancer la
collecte de fonds l'association est
installée à villejuif à proximité du
célèbre institut but à bruz si l'arc et
son président on finançait beaucoup de
choses dans cet incident il me prend
d'une telle place qu'en 1988 ligat tire
la sonnette d'alarmé
l'importance de l'arc fait courir un
risque à l'indépendance des équipes à
l'époque le président de l'arc balaie
ces remarques d'un revers de la main
je demande pas être remercié vais je
vois quand même quand nous facilite la
tâche plutôt que de nous embêter avec
des problèmes aussi bête que ce rapport
de l'igas
si la justice à la demande de l'arc qui
va stopper les investigations successifs
de l'igas en 1991 les chercheurs savent
qu'ils ne touchent que la portion
congrue de la collecte mais il ne se
révolteront jamais contre l'arc en effet
aujourd'hui l'argent privé représente
plus de la moitié des budgets
d'équipement des laboratoires
les certaines idées sur ce public sont
plus sûrs a priori qu'une source
associative surtout dans les temps qui
courent mais
je suis réaliste je fais avec le monde
tel qu'ils existent et non pas tel que
j'aimerais qu'il fut et aujourd'hui
l'argent privé l'argent hors état ou
université sait combien de votre budget
de fonctionnement
aujourd'hui c'est 50 5% et le sens
d'argent là il ya plus de laboratoires
sans les 55% moi je ne travaille plus
demain le conseil d'administration de
l'arq se réunir à villejuif on dit qu'un
changement important la tête de
l'organisation pourrait se produire
l'arc est régie par la loi de 1901 sur
les associations
la polémique actuelle repose de
questions quelles sont les obligations
légales des associations qui vivent de
la générosité publique et surtout
l'utilisation de cet argent et elle
sérieusement contrôlé dans la réalité
crépon